so hi everyone I'm very happy to
introduce our recent work so this is
Joint work with grandson back
and let's start by considering our
scenario where we have two agents Ali
[ __ ] they want to predict their
election outcome and the outcome is a
random variable W which can be DLR
um Alice has a private information x a
bob has a private information XP and
they want to exchange their uh possibly
very complicated
private information According to some
protocol
and they also share some common
knowledge like their joint distribution
over their private information and their
outcome w
so basically they just um alternate
making
announcements that can depend on the
private information and the previous
announcements and why example can be
easy just
um alternate announcing their posterior
belief about the election outcome
so here is a concrete example
so considering I mean uh their
conditioning on the icon they are
private information just like ID bits
um and conditioning on the uh the
outcome is like d Wings in the end and
the probability allies receive one will
be 90 and same for Bob and I mean the um
prior probability for the outcome is 50
50. so they have these private
information uh Alice receives one Bob
receives several and first at least will
declare her posterior conditioning on
her private information which is one
with and like in in such case she will
believe she will believe like with a 90
probability D wins and then Bob actually
can infers from Alice
um declaration in first that as actually
receives one and in that case Bob will
update his belief to this posterior
conditioning or his private information
zero and the fact that Alice received
one and in such cases go back to 50 and
Bob will announce the belief and in that
case because Alias knows that Bob
already
um infers her information and and a
report aggregated information so Alex
will updates her belief to 50 too and
announce it
and they just reach an agreement
so
um in fact
um Omen proves that like regardless what
what protocol they use
um as long as they are believed for this
probability is a common knowledge
between them and in that case they must
have the same belief and in other case
like they just cannot agree to disagree
and here comes to Natural question and
the first question is okay how long like
they need to reach this agreement to
have this common knowledge and and also
um does this agreement imply that
um they are in private information is
already being aggregated
into the first questions Aaron said in
2004 proves that they can actually reach
their agreement
um like like quickly
um so basically it's like
um it depends on how they agree in the
end
and that even though they can reach
their agreement quickly
um still we have the question does this
agreement mean for
and sometimes the answer is no
um let's consider this counter example
so here we are we can we come to this
different situation and in the previous
situation Alex and Bob's and private
information are independent conditioning
on the outcome here they are private
they are just like each of them flip a
coin
independently and so but and and the
outcome depends on the X the x or sorry
the outcome is x r of their
um results of the current flares in such
case their private information
Independence but conditional outcome it
is not independent it's just like the
opposite case of the previous
um example and here in this case like
let's assume that ice receives health
and Bob receives tales and first Alice
will declare 50 which is her posterior
belief conditioning on her private
information but in fact no matter Alice
received has a Tales she wear they heard
her posteriority at least 50 in such
case Bob infers nothing from at least
declaration and he will report his
posterior belief based on his private
information still 15 and same thing like
as SM Alice from aim for anything
from that either and this is Rich
agreements but this agreement actually I
mean doesn't aggregate the information
because if we really
um explicitly review their information
they could determine the outcome so here
in this situation the rich agreements
but it doesn't mean aggregation and we
call this scenario false agreement and
if it's more than two people this call
is False Consensus
and he and and then the question changed
okay if like like we already showed that
agreement may not imply irrigation then
we are curious then when does agreement
implied aggregation
and this is a question this paper is
interesting so we actually provide a
natural information theoretic framework
to solve this question and it also
reproves these previous quick consensus
query consensus results
okay so here is the main theorem
um so we consider scenario where Alice
involves private information or
independent condition independent
conditioning on outcome and intuitively
it just means that there are private
information similar they're just like
substitutes
and we show that in this substitute
setting no matter what communication
protocols they use
um actually approximate agreements we
are like formally defined agreement
later actually implies that
Z actually gets this um an approximate
aggregation so basically their
agreements almost uh their agreement
approximately Aggregates all of their
private information
and okay so before we talk about the
firmware thing let's talk about this um
however proof so the kilometer here is
that
um if their information satisfy the
substitute structure we will we can
prove this subjectivity it's like the
value which we will like Define it and
formula later so the value of their the
the value of their private information
is is less than the sum the sum of the
value of their individual private
information okay so this is this sub
additivity and with this subjectivity we
can prove that okay so conditioning on
the history everyone agrees like
approximately and in that case it
actually implies that conditioning
history like we're I like the uh sorry
if like Alex agrees approximately which
means that her private information is
has um a smaller
um like it's like uh its value is more
now and also like the value of above
property information is also smaller I
mean otherwise they will disagree
um and then these important thing is
like because of this self-relativity if
the individual values more than the
value of even we put their private
information together is also small and
if like if even we put there together
it's also small condition on the history
it means that the history has already
aggregated our information and that
means aggregation so here is this high
level
um proof for this main results and
um we will see that using the right
information theoretic framework of this
definition for value and the
subjectivity uh they can all like follow
naturally
okay
so let's
um talk about
um like the former proof so we first
introduced some information Theory
backgrounds
um even if you're not very familiar with
it we we can just like talk about this
high level idea
so considering we have like three random
variables x y z the entropy of a random
variable measures uncertainty of the
random variable so if it's not random
it's the deterministic it has zero
entropy
and the conditioner entropy regarding
like two random variables it means that
conditioning is is like it's kind of
like giving one random variable what
what is answered remaining uncertainty
of the other random variable expectation
and the mutual information measures they
are like sharing information between
them it's kind of like they are
correlation
and here is similar analogous definition
for the conditional conditioning I've
given some like Z was the remaining
unexpected shared information between X
and Y and here comes a not very commonly
used information
theoretic concept which record this
interaction information so it actually
measures like the shared information
among three random variables it can be
also written as the mutual information
between X and Y minus the conditional
Ministry information between X and Y
conditioning on D
so in fact we can understand everything
intuitively using this Venn diagram so
the set each individual set can be
understood as this entropy individual
entropy and the the like important thing
is this like this intersection of this
three thing it we can understand it as
this um interact inter sorry it's uh
um interaction information among these
three variables and we can also like
this conditioning thing is like some is
is also like the differ operation in the
accessory so basically we can understand
everything using this blend diagram
and dealing with this background we can
formally Define what does that mean for
this approximate agreement
um so we see like a round T it changed
this approximate it's like more than two
people and approximately a consensus I
mean that for all individual agents the
mutual information between her private
information x i the elect outcome W uh
conditionings or history like HT is
history conditioning on the the previous
like the history tea rounds
um announcements is less than Epsilon so
basically this another thing that's like
conditioning on the t-rounds history
asianized Prime information has small
Mutual information with outcome
intuitively it just means that this is
like a individual value of this private
information is not very significant here
so in that case we just see that it's
like for RH satisfy this in court here
we just see that they all Reach This
Epsilon Mutual information consensus
okay
and
um and then we can prove this Lemma
things are like if we have this
substitute structure and then we will
have this sub on additivity so
um so basically it's a kind of like
modern thing here is like One X and Y
are independent continue on Z we can
prove first
um they have a non-nactive interaction
information
and that actually implies that this
condition young acts thing will reduce
the mutual information between Y and Z
and it's like also similar for like this
is just all symmetric so it's the same
for what like why the x or the X Y
and and and and then this actually
implies this on some additivity like the
mutual information between D and X and Y
is less than the military information
between D and x and plus the mutual
information between the and Y
and
um
sorry so these three things can be
actually proved by this Venn diagram so
the reason why Independence like like
like the first like the noun negative
interaction information
because we can write down the interact
in the interaction information Max and Y
and Z as the mutual information between
X and Y minus the conditional Mutual
information between X and Y conditioning
on D which is zero One X and Y are
independent conditionally so in that
case we have is is like this equals the
mesh information between X and Y and
mutual like interaction information can
be positive can be negative but Mutual
information is always part series when
person property
and because of that this is like
positive and and for other like
conditional reduce connection reduce
Mutual information cell additivity image
information we can just like
um prove that according to the channel
or I mean use this Venn diagram just
think this Mutual information as in
transaction and this conditional thing
as they're like the first assessing diff
like operation
okay
so I mean this is like if we
um have this information theoretic
background and then we can easily prove
that when this is substitutes we have
this sub additivity of the mirror
information
and that actually
provide provides us a formal proof for
our main results so after T rounds the
we have like the edge the capital HT
represents all the the
public announcements during the tea runs
and after two runs we get we aggregate
the amount information we aggregated is
the mutual information between the two
rounds announcement in HT and outcome w
but in fact if we can explicitly reveal
our agents private information I mean
the total amount of information we can
aggregate is the measure information
between all private information x y x 2
and txn and outcome w
such case the amount of information that
hasn't been aggregated is your
difference
and
um
by using some chance Theory just using
the general again this exactly is the
conditional conditional Mutual
information between all people's private
information and W condition in the
history and
um and in that case we can just use the
subjectivity if they are I mean if they
are all if conditioning um W or people's
private information Independence
um like this substitution we can prove
this
we just generalized our previous Lemma
to end people and prove this sub
activity for an agents and in such case
this condition the conditions are mutual
information between all private
information W conditional history is
less than the sum of this individual
private information the mutual
information between prime information X
and W conditional history and I mean as
we Define before here they already reach
this Epsilon
amount Epsilon Mutual information
consensus so the individual Mutual
information will be less than Epsilon
and in total it will less than an
Epsilon so
here this is like this former
information theoretic proof
and in fact like we mentioned before
within this information theoretic
framework we can also
um prove this quick consensus result
quickly
um
like basically we have a very natural
potential function which is aggregate
information like we mentioned before the
mutual information between these g-runs
and public announcements NW and also we
we need to kind of like
um analyze the growth rate of this
potential function and this is like this
amount of information of their
declaration like we just use this small
h i t to represent at wrong T agent eyes
public announcements so basically the
growth rates basically equals the
conditional conditioning or Mutual
information between Asian Ice public
declaration
um like like for for Asian Island
um
her public declaration and outcome
conditioning on what happens before she
makes her announcements
and here comes through this queer
consensus scene so basically once some
of them has like large disagreements
they just like disagree with
um
like
um
uh with with other people in that case
her private information actually has a
very high value and in that case if the
protocol is defined properly and
um like we we just use uh the to the the
protocol like people or
um they just exchange their posterior
belief or they just doing this discrete
version of the apostropriably follow
from erinson 2004 within that protocols
we can show that if their private
information has a high value then they
are public declaration will also have a
high value and this actually implies
that the potential the growth rate of
this potential function is large and
this potential function is always I mean
I mean the mutual information of at the
the dimension formation between the
history and outcome is always less than
the
I mean the the entropy of this outcome
is bonded I mean in in this luxury based
in Spanish by one and in that case the
potential function is bondage and it has
a high growth rate and I mean it's just
like it's it's we are a richer consensus
pretty soon
and it also has a connection to this
prediction market so
um basically if we are considered
prediction Market with log scoring row
and people they just change their belief
from this current posterior belief to
their uh to the to their current the
current posterior belief according to
conditioning on the history and to the
posteriorative conditioning history and
her private information in that case
they will be paid these conditional
Mutual information thing and and then
this
um
um absolute information consensus means
that they cannot make a lot of money
expectation using their private
information and the quick consensus
means that the market will quickly reach
conversions and there's no Comfort
consensus substances this means that one
papers information structure satisfies
substitutes then convergence implies
aggregation
okay so here is a summary we propose
this information theoretic framework it
can help us easily prove that no False
Consensus with substitutes and we also
reprove these quick consensus in fact
we'll prove another strategic Revelation
result and you can read papers from our
details and future hopefully this
framework can be employed in other
scenarios like learning like social
network
thanks